this video is brought to you by Paradox
Interactive what's up wisecrack jared
here to talk about the show with the
best fans on the internet Rick and Morty
now the most recent episode is one of
our favorite of the season so far I mean
it's got wet eggs I told you not to look
at that egg it was too wet and well uh
you know honestly I'm proud of us for
not but what we found most interesting
about this episode is the basic question
it poses how much should nature define
us welcome to this wisecrack quick take
on Rick and Morty season 4 episode 7 or
more dias and duh spoilers ahead but
before we get into it I want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor Paradox
Interactive right now they're addictive
game stellaris is available for free on
Steam in this 4x strategy game you get
to customize the universe you pick an
empire name your alien race and explore
space as you progress you'll be able to
colonize and take over the entire
universe you can choose what matters the
most to your native Empire by focusing
on surveying other solar systems growing
your own galaxy's government or by
designing new ships and buildings for
colonies the game is so detailed it
gives you the ability to customize
everything down to the names of the
individual characters you can
micromanage every aspect of your growing
civilization from monitoring trade and
resources to selecting government
leaders while also focusing on the big
stuff like growing your battleships or
colonizing other planets this week the
game is celebrating its 4th anniversary
which means you can play for free right
now when you click the link in the
description and now back to the show so
the basic premise of primordius is this
there's a parasitic face-hugging alien
species that exerts total control of
their hosts and has a lifespan of about
30 minutes after depositing an egg said
hosts explodes killing itself and the
Proud parasite mommy suck on a face an
egg die but some are using a foolproof
oral defense mechanism escapes
enslavement and convinces the parasites
to forego their reproductive urges to
live a longer more fulfilling life as a
result the parasites are able to quickly
build a sprawling society with media
matching skyscrapers and pearl harbors
and then
course Rick blows it all up - the twin
skyscrapers of course totally
it would have been cheap yeah real
low-hanging fruit we're better than that
also jerry has bees I think one of the
most interesting elements of this
episode lies in this small gag parasite
Rick Gloria - Brants against the
progressive agenda of living longer now
at first this seems like a quick jab at
people like alex jones did tonight at
least sell out and sell vitamins or
something but the basic concept is
mirrored everywhere in the episode that
is if something is natural does that
make it right
facehugger rick's argument for the
murder-suicide of hosts in parasite is
based on quote unquote science host of
course this is not actually science it's
the mention of science and a logical
fallacy we appeal to nature fallacy that
is the idea that if something is natural
it is inherently good desirable or even
inevitable this kind of fallacy pops up
everywhere in the debate about same-sex
marriage many people would argue that
homosexuality was unnatural and
therefore immoral then again getting
mauled by a tiger is perfectly natural
but that doesn't mean it's good this is
the appeal to nature fallacy in action
others would point to the fact correctly
that homosexuality is natural among many
of our closest animal relatives which
again is still a logical fallacy since
dictating where you can or can't stick
your genitals based on what does or
doesn't happen in nature is a logical
fallacy this fallacy also pops up around
the idea that might is right the idea
that people are justified to rule by
strength alone that claim usually gets
backed by citing Darwinism whatever
primates do or don't do in the wild or
our evolutionary history of humans being
dicks pretty much every time you hear
about monkeys primates or our cavemen
ancestors you should stop listening to
that person except that's a fallacy
fallacy dismissing a conclusion outright
because it's logic was flawed anyway
everyone shut up about monkeys already
parasite Rick's argument is exactly this
kind of appeal to nature he says we
should deposit our eggs because the host
can biologically sustain them he also
has a poster on his wall that displays a
kind of might is Right logic reading
that glory
our supreme and hosts are subservient
which echoes plenty of bad appeals to
nature found in places like social
Darwinism the progress of summer on the
other hand is about moving past biology
determining one's future let's just get
the hell out of here and be whatever the
[ __ ] we want that's evolution that's
progress but there's also a more subtle
critique going on here important to this
episode and life is that people when
appealing to nature often set up an
arbitrary divide between good nature and
bad nature oh yeah now you respect like
the biological institutions now you
people arguing that same-sex marriage is
bad because it's unnatural usually have
no problem watching YouTube for 8 hours
a day getting blood transfusions or
being temperature regulated by the
liquid remains of dinosaurs
similarly parasite rick has no problem
enjoying the unnatural spoils of
civilization or non-reproductive
arguably incestual face sucking while
railing against the repression of
biological processes inside this old man
yeah because I do what I want similarly
one could respect nature while despising
parts of it that seem a key or just
dangerous like snakes which have
historically been labeled in some
cultures as evil incarnate and of course
there's parasites which to my knowledge
don't really have too many positive
representations in the media it's pretty
much a default to think of them as
mindless their face hugging parasites I
don't think their society's gonna be
that hard to navigate and but here's
where the episode gets really
interesting because this looking down on
our face huggers is in a weird way a
mirror image of parasite rick normal
rick views parasites as lowly a lesser
form of life as rick and morty commit
mass murder they note how good it feels
to cause mayhem without guilt and feels
kind of good when there's no guilt just
like in Star Wars comparing it to
popping bubble wrap not destroying an
advanced civilization but this idea is
constantly undercut as the show likens
Rick and Morty's violence to American
tragedies so you did a 9/11 almost we
went with a Pearl Harbor we're pretty
classy why were either of those an
option or two even comments echoing
might is right justification for
destroying their world before becoming
horrified by his actions it's not all
that different than parasite Rick's
justification for enslaving host species
humans killing parasites is just some
old-fashioned natural pest control even
if by some unnatural means there's also
just a really interesting question here
that I love there's a basic hypothetical
is it fair to call a species evil for
just reproducing as their nature
dictates what would happen if we
encountered an intelligent alien that
could only survive by living
parasitically off another sentient alien
is there even a line in the sand we can
draw as a species that lives off eating
other species just some food for thought
and before we go I want to give one
final shout out to Paradox Interactive
and their strategy games stellaris
create and customize an empire to take
over the universe research other solar
systems and foster your Empire's economy
right now you can play for free by
clicking the link in the description
big shout out to our patrons for
supporting us and we'll see you next
time guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]